Okay, Michael, so you might ask me why we would
do feature transformation, and I think the answer is obvious
even to the most casual observer. We actually just went
through a couple of examples in the previous slide, like X
or the kernal methods, all these things we've done before
where effectively we were doing feature transformation. In fact, you
could argue that things like neural networks. Already doing feature
transformation. So we've been doing feature transformation all along, and so,
the real question here is, is there some specific
reason why we should do this feature transformation explicitly and
separate from some specific learning algorithm that is doing its
own feature transformation such as a perceptron or a neural
network, or support vector machines. So i'm just going to very
quickly go through a simple example that I hope illustrates
why you might want to do this, but it's still
kind of a large relevant example okay. You with me?
>> I'm ready.
>> Okay,
so here's the problem, I'm going to describe, and I'm not going to do it
in a lot of detail. I, I really just want to give you an
intuition. That problem is inforfmation retrieveal.
So in particular, I'm talking about what's
called, ad hoc retrieval. Do you know what the ad hoc retrieval problem is?
>> I assume that if you start with a
key, and you add hoc to it, you get hockey.
>> No, that would be a kind of feature transformation.
We would call that the pun transformation.
The ad hoc retrieval problem, maybe I can
help you out by calling it by another
nickname, it's the Google problem [LAUGH] which is,
you have a whole bunch of documents in
some database somewhere. This is me drawing a
database and you want to retrieve exactly the subset
of documents that are relevant to some query.
[SOUND]
So this is me drawing a data base. So I
might type in a word like machine-learning, into some text
box somewhere, click on some button, and then get back
a list of relevant documents nicely sorted against the white background.
>> [LAUGH] And this is the ad hoc query problem, the ad hoc retrieval
problem. I give you some features, which in this case are words, and you return
objects, in this case documents, that are somehow relative to the,
relevant to those features. Okay? So we do this all the time.
>> What makes it ad hoc as, as opposed
to what? There's various other kinds of information retrieval problems,
this one's just called that ad hoc one. What's ad
hoc about it is you don't already know what the
queries are. You aren't doing something like clustering the
documents. It's just that you're going to be given some unknown
query, which is in some feature space, and you're just
going to have to retrieve the things that are relevant so.
Its just always been called the ad hoc problem as far as I
know. I guess because you don't know what these are going to be beforehand.
>> Yeah, and like as opposed to maybe some kind of standing query, like
I want any information that talks about
the OMS program, you know, please alert me.
>> Right, exactly, and that's actually got
a name too, it's not the standing query
problem, but it's a kind of triage problem,
I can't remember what it's called right now.
But yeah, so there's different versions of this. This one is in some
ways the hardest, because you can't do a lot of very clever things up
front, in order to figure out the best way to store your documents,
because you don't know what this ad hoc query is going to be. Okay?
>> Yup.
>> All right. So. Why is this problem
hard, other than by saying I don't know what
this is going to be? So let's think about
it in terms of the features that you have.